we take PFT p.m. earlier today I guess
this technically then becomes PFT p.m.
PS because after we concluded our late
afternoon session regarding among other
things the situation in Washington the
Washington Post article finally has been
published and it identifies 15 former
female employees who claim that they
were sexually harassed during their time
with the franchise now only one of them
is named the other fourteen have decided
not to allow their name to be published
because of non-disclosure agreements
that were signed that expressly
threatened potential litigation if they
talk about things that happened while
they work for the team now to know more
about what exactly would have been left
by them to the team and therefore to
allow us to know more about what maybe
owner dat owner dana snyder knew at the
time these agreements were negotiated
we'd have to know more about the
specifics of the agreements it's
possible these are just general
severance agreements that these
individuals signed without ever making
specific detailed allegations that would
have put daniel snyder on notice that he
has a problem but the portrait painted
by this story
reasonably when putting on notice that
he has a problem and even though there
are no specific allegations made against
him the three individuals who are named
as having allegedly done things they
shouldn't have done Larry Michael Alex
Santos Richard Mann the second all three
of them have left the team in recent
days Michael play-by-play voice of the
team for 16 years
abruptly retired on Wednesday and most
people thought maybe it has something to
do with this story clearly it did Santos
was the director of pro Carson now man
was the assistant director of personnel
they were both fired over the weekend so
there have been consequences for the
individuals who were accused of
wrongdoing you can reasonably conclude
that whatever investigation the team did
allowed it to conclude that the
individuals were responsible for the
things they were accused of doing but no
accusations against Snyder no
accusations against Bruce Allen the
longtime president of the team which
makes this situation different for
Snyder than it was in Carolina several
years ago for
Richardson when the founder of the team
had to abruptly sell the team after it
came out that there were multiple
non-disclosure agreements based upon
allegations of misconduct
all of which traced back to him in this
case there's nothing tracing back
specifically to Snyder but the problem
is this everything traces back to Snyder
generally he's not an absentee landlord
like other owners who live in one city
and owned a team in a different city
he's there he's present this is his
culture
this is his organization he's been the
owner for 21 years if he's not aware of
the things that are happening under his
watch then he's clueless
and see in order to avoid significant
scrutiny from the league office or his
business partners who own the other 31
franchises Snyder essentially has to
characterize himself as being completely
and totally clueless as to the things
happening in his building and that's
gonna be hard to pull off the article
creates the impression that this all
began at the top this atmosphere began
at the top how employees are treated
specific allegation of damage Snyder
berating a male employee no allegation
of sexual misconduct against a female
employee but comments made allegedly by
Snyder that would then trickle down
because see the person who runs the
organization does indeed set the tone
and it's fair to infer that the tone
that was set by Snyder was indeed copied
mimicked perpetuated by the people
working under them and the bottom line
is if it was as prevalent as these 15
individuals would seem to suggest Snyder
surely knew or at a minimum should have
known what was going on so what happens
moving forward we watch and see what the
reaction to this story is how much
pressure creates for the Washington
franchise how much pressure it places on
the league and on other teams to account
guys' will that be enough to force the
kind of action that would result in
Snyder selling the team this is why he's
hired an outside lawyer to come in and
conduct this investigation he wants the
end result to be Daniel Snyder is
blameless
not nothing about these specific
activities Daniel Snyder had no reason
to go in and clean up a mess because he
didn't know a mess existed again to sell
that he's going to have to be willing to
make himself look clueless either way
it's not a good look and either way
depending upon how things unfold it's
the kind of situation that could create
serious problems for his ongoing
ownership of the team dak Prescott
Cowboys quarterback with comments to USA
Today after it became clear that he
would not have a long-term contract he
plays under the franchise tag this year
it was a tweet from his brother
yesterday suggesting frustration on the
part of the family and maybe an idea
that dak Prescott is not going to be
with the Cowboys very long Prescott said
I'm a cowboy and couldn't be happier
well he's a cowboy now he's a cowboy
this year it's determined for 2020 what
is it determined is what happens next
year and I've had so many fans say oh
dak Prescott [ __ ] assume he's gonna
make 37.6 eight million next year
the Cowboys may not be able to afford to
tag him again they may not want to tag
him again ok fine number one they're
gonna find another quarterback if that's
the case number
you
he goes the nice bitter see he's a
winner here either way he's getting
thirty one point four million for this
year he still makes a decent amount of
money and by decent I mean in the seven
figures off the field in endorsements
he's got the money to buy an insurance
policy to protect him against a
catastrophic injury that would take away
that big pile of guaranteed money he's
eventually going to get okay fine
next year the Cowboys need to pay him
thirty seven point six eight million or
they signed with a long-term contract or
they let him walk away in free agency
and it becomes the new Kirk Cousins
who signs a three-year hundred and ten
million dollar contract or something
like that on the open market it's it's
good for him either way
setting aside everything beyond 2020 the
guys getting thirty one point four
million this year what's he got to be
upset about
so uncertainty as to the future but no
uncertainty as to 2020 at least as it
relates to who the quarterback will be
for the Cowboys we don't know where that
I think are playing games but we do know
that if they ultimately suit up and go
it will be duck breast card at
quarterback all season long we also know
that as he qlae will continue to be the
starting running back of the Dallas
Cowboys last year he held out for most
if not all of training camp and into the
preseason to get the contract that he
deserved based upon his first three
years in the NFL now he's sought in see
there's a lot of salty players right now
between preseason rankings and Madden
ratings you know the Madden ratings are
generally worthless except for the fact
that they piss guys off and they give
guys motivation calimary salty about his
lady on Bell salty about his well Zika
soggy about something he said there are
a lot of great backs in this league but
I don't understand why the media has to
talk down on my game just to uplift
other backs we're all talented football
players and Ken ball check the stats
since I entered this league I have
dominated year in year up with some
respect on my name women lie men lie the
stats don't go to your homework almost
1800 scrimmage yards and 14 touchdowns
with no training camp and now I'm not
the same back I do appreciate the
standard you guys hold me to though but
I promise you no one holds me to a
higher standard than myself and he's
right he had a great year last year he
just wasn't the guy that he was his
first three seasons something Simms
spotted early in the year and it lasted
all year long when he would get through
to the second level
he didn't have that same explosion where
he ran away from everybody that 10-yard
run didn't become a 50-yard run so he
started a great year but it could have
been better and maybe it wasn't as good
as it could be because he didn't have
the benefit of training camp he went to
Mexico while they were working out the
contract and you know anytime a guy
misses that much time there's a chance
it's gonna affect his performance and
think of how good he would have been if
he'd been around for all of training
camp but he's still one of the great
running backs in the NFL and between him
and Amari Cooper who signed a contract
to stay with the team see he'll am their
first-round pick who fell into their
laps dak Prescott the offensive line not
as dominant as it was in recent years
but still pretty good and maybe the
defense better now new coaching staff
new approach Cowboys can end up being
good this year again if they end up
playing any games at all and here's
hoping that they play all of their games
all 16 not 12 not 10 not 9 all 16
postseason maybe for the Cowboys and
let's know it all plays out all right we
do know that this will be a different
season in a lot of respects if they do
get all the regular season games in
there will be no fans at training camp
teams had started to announce one by one
that they won't have fans at training
camp and as every team did it it was
news and I kind of took a step back and
we had a little session with the PFT
writers and I said hey folks I don't
really think this is news I think it's
already been decided
there won't be fans at training camp I
checked with the league and the league
said you're correct no fans at training
camp all the teams can do this year they
can have up to two events at their
stadium if local and state law allows it
and if they can otherwise conduct the
thing in compliance with NFL procedures
and protocols that's it two events at
the stadium forever you have your
training camp you're not going to have
fans there this year period it's not
going to happen for any team even if
you're a team where you're in a location
that has a drop in the koban 19 cases
and everything's fine and people wear
their masks in the socially distance
there's gonna be no fans of training
camp anywhere and obviously that's gonna
be a huge difference from past years and
let me lost money coming from that
because you know the teams find a way to
make a little money off of it although I
don't think you if you charge that the
rule
I need a refresher on on this at one
point if you charge for anything at camp
then scouts from other teams were
allowed to be there and I think
Washington fell into that trap at one
point several years ago but they found a
way to allow teams to make their money
without an open invitation for other
teams to show up for training camp and
the Scout their training camp practices
but bottom line is the bottom line will
be affected by fans not at training camp
and the money this year is going to come
primarily from televised regular season
games anything else that NFL teams over
and above that is going to be a bonus
whether it's 20% capacity for games
40% whatever percent 1% it's gonna be
more than what they're otherwise gonna
make because I think you just have to go
into the season assuming that no fans
are going to be involved and even if you
can do these two events with fans
present how many teams are really gonna
be able to pull that off given where the
pandemic currently is really how many T
fans of teams are gonna want to show up
for something like that
in places where the virus currently is
running roughshod roughshod sins we're
gonna be ready for all the Sims isms to
return when we start PFT live up again
next week alright there's been some
reporting that the NFL mean about
Players Association are at odds over
whether or not players who test positive
for the virus will be on injured reserve
or the non football illness list now the
non football illness list if you put a
player on that during the season they're
done for the year and they potentially
if the team chooses not to pay them
don't get another penny as if last night
ESPN was reporting that's still a
sticking point I had other people saying
it's not a sticking point we have a deal
on what it's going to be Meyers standing
and this is all subject to legal prove
oh but the deal between the league and
the union will allow players to be
placed on a short-term kovat 19 I or
lift and then they come off of that list
and go back to the roster and while they
are on that list they will be replaced
on the roster by someone else the goal
is to ensure that you have as many
healthy bodies as possible
you have maximum flexibility now the way
it was explained to me three weeks on
the Cova 19 list then you can return to
practice and once you get to the point
where you can return to practice you've
got a three week window to get back to
the active roster at the end of that
three weeks
it's either active roster injured
reserve or injury element and the player
leaves the team I've heard some concerns
from the player's perspective about why
do you have to be shut down for three
weeks on the front end what if you're
asymptomatic what if within five days
you can generate two negative tests why
should you be kept off of a roster for
three whole weeks
simply because you tested positive and
you have no symptoms so there may be
some lingering push and pull on the
contours of the Cova 19 I or list and
frankly if you're the team why do you
want to have your guys set aside for a
minimum of three weeks that doesn't make
any sense if there is a way they can get
back sooner than that
but that's where it currently stands
we'll see how that plays out but the
teams are not going to do anything to
have rules that are so rigid that the
players get screwed because it's not
their fault if they test positive and
you're never gonna be able to prove that
it didn't happen at work so the players
get paid whatever the final rules are
and the final rules will encourage the
ability for teams to have as many
players available as possible you want
to be able to withstand an outbreak you
want to be able to plug in other players
and you don't want a situation where
your players who have tested positive
are still taking up roster spots that
could be devoted to players who are
negative for the virus and who could
come in even if they're only there for a
couple of weeks and I think we'll also
see some flexibility on the moves that
are made on the practice squad already
for this year you can move guys two of
them up and down without passing them
through waivers I suspect that maybe
more guys from the practice squad will
be eligible to go up to the active
roster and then back down in the event
of a coded 19 positive designation
without passing through waivers and
giving another team a chance to pounce
on a guy who goes from the active roster
back to the practice squad so let me get
this all figured out if they want
training camp to open a lot of people
are
it really doesn't make sense the open
training camp right now especially in
the cities that are in the midst of the
greatest rate of increased cases like
Houston like Dallas like Miami like LA
whatever the final decision we are at
the point where decisions need to be
made and I'd say by this time tomorrow
when we do Friday's pft p.m. we should
be at a point where we have a pretty
good idea of what the rules are and what
the rules aren't so teams either will or
won't be proceeding with training camp
and I will not be surprised if the end
result is they decide to get rid of the
preseason and bump everything back a
couple of weeks and give everyone a
chance to really prepare for what's to
come because once they're there they're
there you don't want to start it up and
then shut it down you want to wait until
the point where you're confident you can
get it wrong and it's gonna work right
it's and if you rush and this was the
sentiment the JJ Watt shared with us
last week if you rush when you shouldn't
you may have the season collapse when it
otherwise
we'll see how it all plays out we're
hoping for football season again
addressing the various hurdles the NFL
faces does not in any way mean we are
rooting against it why in the hell and
almost said a word stronger than Elwood
we root against it we want football
we can't wait for football and hopefully
football will find a way to coexist with
a pandemic that has gotten worse instead
of better because there are too many
stupid selfish people out there who have
failed to take this seriously who have
failed to do what they need to do and
those are kind of people as I said
yesterday who are complaining the most
if there's no football let's all resolve
to do what we need to do let's wear a
mask let's stay home when we need to
let's find a way to do the things that
need to be done in the safest way
possible and let's hope that it's not
too late to salvage football season
check it's not around the clock of pro
football TOCOM again the Washington
story apparently coming tonight will be
all over if it happens and we'll be back
tomorrow for another edition of PFT p.m.
everybody enjoy your day and we'll talk
to you on Friday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports